fiction there is coach kell with us
coach cal is he's the uh kentucky head
coach
joining us did you play football coach
in high school
until i broke my collarbone in three
places and i thought i better start
playing a sport that's left rust but
that's
rough were you any good come on now you
know i was good at everything
ping pong softball baseball football
basketball come on i was a jack of all
trades that was really
not great in anything but i could play
everything still
i can throw a football about 35 yards
right now
spiral tight
that's not that impressive coach what
it's not like i'm 51 years old and i'm
throwing a football 38 yards come on
i'm 64 and i'll throw it 45 yards
no way what do you want about no way
wouldn't you blow out your knee and a
shoulder
no way i've already had my shoulders
have to
they carry you off the field in pain and
you'd sound like a girl screaming
you're out of your mind it is worth
something happening you know to my
shoulder
that just to win this bet i will let you
throw a pie in my
face if you can throw a football [ __ ]
like an nfl football don't give me some
little
air nerf ball i'm talking like the real
football all right how far do you want
me to throw it how far do you want me to
throw it
you can throw it 45 yards there's no way
i listen i can oh my gosh
you're crazy okay you're nuts you've
always been nuts you haven't changed
that's a great thing i love about you
you've been consistent in who you are
thank you
your whole life are you only 51
they're dead i thought you said you were
51 are you 61
what who what are we talking ages here i
don't care if you give up your age at
64. i'm young
i just ask you how old you were
you don't ask people you were telling me
let's start this over he's the kentucky
head coach john calipari joining us on
the program how are you coach
doing good dan how are you everything's
great are we on the air
yeah we weren't on the air
oh um what did you think of the acc
proposal that everybody gets
into the uh the college basketball
tournament march madden is for everybody
um you know truthfully i've spent
absolutely
no time on it because i never considered
it
and dan gavit followed up with
you know we're not doing that so
you know i'll be honest we're going to
have a season
yeah we have to get started november
25th
we have to play uh non-conference games
especially against some of the smaller
schools dan that need
the money and because they play those
quote by games
but they need the money my son plays at
detroit
they need the money and you could say
what you want like some of these
programs if we decide to go league only
they'll be done they're they and if
they're not done
they're going to cut four or five sports
on their campus and take away jobs and
scholarships and
we got to figure this out how we all you
ready for this
survive the ncaa tournament is vital for
everybody all sports it's the one
tournament that makes money the ncaa
that goes to all the other sports
we don't want to see guys losing ladies
lose jobs or sports or
um so i'm concerned that do we do it in
pods
do we do non-conference games in pods do
we go to orlando and play some games
i do know this we can't we can't have
these kids
in a in a in a bubble for 30 days won't
work these kids are 17 and 18
and the mental health issue you know the
pod should
in my mind should not extend more than
seven eight days and then
go back to campus take some time you
know
and and then go do it again if that's
what we choose but what
what are what are you hearing what are
the possibilities like legitimate
possibilities for a college
basketball season in in some way shape
or form
that's happening we'll have a college
season unless something crazy
you know that i'm not seeing okay we'll
have a college season
the question will become all right the
ncaa tournament it can move a little bit
it can move back a little bit if we need
to you have to start november
because you may have some blips that you
need to work through and we need extra
weeks to get ready
i think teams should be able to play as
many non-conference games as they're
allowed
with no limit if there's a limit of 12
then you can play 12.
um if you can't get in 12 and you can
only get an eight
because your team got sick or whatever
else happens that's fine
there's not gonna be competitive equity
stop it
everybody's gonna play the same number a
game how do you do that if the team gets
sick we all stop
the whole country stop while they catch
up you can't
you're not in some teams you're going to
have stronger schedules than other teams
i just hope we don't leave out
the smaller schools that need the
financial help from us bigger schools
so if we're doing non-league games half
of them
should be quote us playing teams and
giving them some money to keep their
programs going
he's the kentucky head coach john
calipari joining us on the program
i know you had uh some not run-ins but
encounters with john thompson i think
when you were at umass you went up
against him at memphis you you coached
against him
yeah got a favorite john thompson story
well i didn't coach against him when i
was at memphis i coached against him
when i was at umass and we were in the
elite eight
against uh alan iverson and the boys he
had a heck of a team that year
and we played him in atlanta um and
he from that game and we i refused to
let my guys
celebrate on the court they didn't
celebrate on the bench
we won the game and we all walked down
and shook his hand and his team hand
but we didn't cut down the net it was
our first final four ever
out of respect for him and he figured
out what we did
and from that time he just became
you know a mentor a friend any time he
saw me you know
hey john he'd scream you know in his big
voice across the room in the final four
to come over and sit with him but
you know how about this courage that he
had how about
he didn't coach a game he just said i'm
not coaching
because this rule i don't care that it's
a rule
it's a bad rule and we need to change
bad rules
this is going to affect black players
african-american players at a higher
rate than anybody
and we can't stand for this and he ends
up
you know being right and what he did and
other coaches joined him but he was the
one that had that kind of courage
um and not worried about he knew what
was right this is right
and what was wrong about all the players
that he coached the
hall of famers that he coached i'll give
you one story
i'm recruiting against him i'm an
assistant epitome
in richmond virginia jim is packed
it was john marshall we were i went to
watch one of their players
and i'm in the gym and it's packed
and i'm watching mom because i want to
see mom's response i'm trying to catch
your eyes so i can wave to her you know
you're not really allowed to speak and i
would never do anything illegal so i was
across the way just waving trying to get
our attention
so all of a sudden the gym
erupted like literally
people in mass jumped up and start
screaming
and i look at mom and she's screaming
and dancing and waving her hands
and i'm like what the hell's going on
here and i look over john thompson had
walked in the gym
you know what i did you left uh
absolutely
i left the program i left
my rental car agreement i left
everything and just left the gym
like why am i here what am i doing uh
did you recruit ewing
no huh okay i was at umass at the time
oh okay i mean yeah he wasn't gonna
hearing anybody would have been somebody
on his bench
matter of fact doing may have been
healing may have been
when i was at pittsburgh you know being
that i'm 51
i'm trying to think back i might have
i might have been a kid at the time
you might be 41 by the time this
interview's over i hope so
hey they they vacated some of my games
maybe
they could take some years off if
they're going to take victories off your
total they can take some years off your
life that'd be nice
what is it like for you to watch the nba
playoffs given
every game every team it feels like has
one of your
former players on it well
starring okay in next year
playing in the game okay so you know
it's really funny to see
jamal murray doing the stuff that he's
doing
seeing uh shay alexander seeing devin
booker
watching bam entire um you know i'm
hitting those guys
i hit him after games and i hit pat
riley and eric spoelstra after the game
what
what what they've done with those two
um and to to believe in them
and they're all young the guys i'm
telling you anthony davis is the one
he's probably 28.
he graduated in 2012 eight years ago he
was 19 so he's 27 28 years old
these other dudes are like 23. i know
and they're they're they're doing it and
and here's what i would say
to come with us you you got to be built
different
and the reason you got to be built
different is that you're going to be on
our team with other really good players
which means
you gotta find your niche you're not
gonna walk in that league
and they're gonna run every play which
is guys that we get big you're going
we're gonna run every play you're gonna
start you're gonna play
i'm never gonna recruit anybody you're
going to be the only guy you're going to
play 40 minutes you're going to do that
then they go to the league and all of a
sudden it's like you got to fight your
way
other guys out there can play our guys
learn that yeah they also learned
if you don't guard you don't play which
is why you could have never played for
me
but they we got three players
on the all defensive team three that
hadn't happened since 77
with three ucla guys coached by john
wooden there were three
we had three eric bledsoe bam
and anthony and anthony should have been
as you know he should have been
defensive player of the year not taken
away from giannis but that's
you know you just did
no i did and and who is the great
defensive coach on your staff at
kentucky
who helped it's not me i know when i was
in college
my coach was a 1-3-1 you know where he
put me
underneath the basket yes he did yeah
until we played a team that put two
seven footers right next to me
and started throwing balls up in the air
and then he went away from it you know
what he did
what defense his defense was son you
can't play you're out let's play
somebody else
the 31 year old john calipari joining us
on the program uh coach it's uh great to
talk to you as always and uh i'll send
you video of me throwing the football
once we can get out
and uh you know i'll go to a football
field we'll measure it off
i'll throw it and then if you will
administer a pie to how about your wife
hits you
in the face with a pie or your daughter
um well either one would try to hurt me
i probably have
yeah and brad would try to hurt me too
but aaron and megan they just get oh my
oldest daughter oh
she is mean really smart girl
both of them are really smart but i'm
really mean we'll just have your wife do
it
i'm not gonna give her the pleasure no
it's not gonna happen so why are we even
talking about it you're gonna
i will promise you this i will go visit
you at the hospital as they try to put
your shoulder back in or you
repair your knee that blew out when you
tried to step to throw it i already have
a replacement knee and i had labrum
surgery three years ago i prepaid for
another surgery coach
it was a two for one i knew you were two
for one guy i knew
it's great to talk to you and uh
hopefully we'll have a basketball season
to talk about thank you coach
bye-bye that's coach cow
you know those are the conversations we
have when we're in person or on the
phone
not on the show so that's how it goes
back and forth with him